Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks for submitting
questions for this week’s doctor who Q&A.
And thanks to everyone who’s commented on
the new look I have going on here.
I am working on sound proofing so there won’t
be an echo anymore.
I just flipped my camera around so it wasn’t
the white wall.
I just thought this would be more fun to stare
at.
Here are a few quick additional notes from
the episode before we get to questions.
First commenter Jon Ellis pointed out that
The Cave where the merry men hid out was also
the place they filmed the Sherlock hound of
baskerville episode.
And the doctor has been seen with matt smith’s
sonic filming in future episodes.
So he didn’t permanently lose it.
I address the deleted scene in the q&a.
But careful for spoilers from robot of sherwood
if you haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
Here we go
Question 1 - Kevin G asks Is the Promised
Land Gallifrey?
I definitely think Gallifrey, The Promised
Land and Missy’s Heaven are all connected.
Even if they’re not all the same place.
We know Gallifrey is in the pocket Universe
and we know Missy is the Gatekeeper of the
Nethersphere.
We don’t know what that is yet, but because
of all the dead people she’s saving it’s
implied that she might have time lord like
abilities.
After Deep Breath initially I thought the
promised land was more of a metaphor unique
to each character.
Like the clockwork droid’s idea of the promised
land was something created by his own mind.
And the Doctor’s idea of the promised land
was gallifrey.
I don’t think the robots in episode 3 or
the clockwork droids were trying to get to
Gallifrey.
Otherwise the screen would have read gallifrey.
I think they’re responding to a summons
of sorts.
Like something is calling them to the promised
land.
That could be missy’s doing.
But it starting to seem like everyone will
have the same reason for wanting to go there.
Question 2 - Hydra da Little asks Earth has
a twin planet called Mondas, what if that’s
what the Promised Land image was?
Another good theory, Cybermen play a big role
this series in some mysterious way.
If gallifrey is coming back, so could mondas
too.
There have been a lot of spoilery images of
the finale that add some fuel to the fire
but since a lot of you requested I not show
them.
I’ll let you guys just do a google image
search.
In terms of specific planets there are a few
strong candidates that I’ll mention in a
slightly different question later in this
video.
I’m also starting to think of the promised
land as a missy trap of sorts.
Maybe not a trap for the doctor, but a trap
for everyone else.
It would sync up with the idea of robin hood
entering the archery contest knowing full
well it was a trap.
Question 3 - Big ‘N Wide asks there have
been reports of a lot of familiar filming
locations from the place Kamelion was killed
by the fifth doctor as well as Fires of Pompeii
imagery.
All tying in with the idea the doctor is leaving
himself subconscious messages.
What are some theories for how this will be
explained?
Right now from a third person perspective
it seems like the common theme of the reminders
is that The Doctor has been playing god.
Altering time when it suits him, choosing
who he saves and who he allows to die.
Usually you leave yourself a reminder when
you want to remember to take an action.
I’m hoping the next villain Ms Delphox and
the futuristic bank gives us some more clues.
That episode is number 5, so it’s in 2 weeks.
Question 4 - Matt dosko asks Which historical
character do you want the doctor to meet next?
I’m really looking forward to the Mummy
on the Orient express episode and who might
show up in that from egyptian mythology.
I don’t know who Foxes is playing, but I
think it’s just a lounge singer, I don’t
think she’s playing cleopatra.
Question 5 - Oli Kidsley asks Do you like
the faster pace of the episodes so far?
This episode felt like it was meant to be
more of a reflection on the journey so far.
Yes, I do really like Capaldi’s pacing.
I think a lot of it has to do with what the
actor’s bring to the role.
Capaldi developed this amazing persona with
Malcolm Tucker.
So I think it’s much more natural for him
as an actor to replicate that energy.
But it’s fun to see him change that and
hold back in a scene.
Like with the apple and the sonic.
It makes watching the really old classic who
episodes a trip, just because television in
general was much more about long dialogue
scenes.
And now you see a lot more jump cutting and
explosions.
Question 6 - Joey Gmaj asks how do you feel
about the BBC cutting the beheading scene?
Did you want to see it?
I think it was totally appropriate given real
life circumstances.
Their reason for taking it out was good.
I didn’t watch the leaked episodes so I
didn’t know what the scene was.
I’ve read since then that it presents the
Sheriff as a half man half robot.
Mark Gatiss said technically he didn’t write
Robot of Sherwood to fit inside the Missy
plot, but it’s possible that the half man
half robot thing was foreshadowing for cybermen?
I’m okay without seeing it though.
I don’t think it’s a huge deal.
If it were something really really big, they’d
probably just post it digitally so people
could watch it if they wanted.
Question 7 - The New View Production says,
Rachel Talalay the director of the finale
said to count the number of planets in the
opening titles.
Is there a hint about missy in this?
Yes, here’s the message she tweeted out
that you’re referring to.
She posted this very recently.
And for reference, she directed both the final
two episodes.
it’s a two parter, but they’re airing
them one week apart.
They won’t air back to back.
Most of what I’ve read about this focuses
more on the big big planet that we can see
really well.
The best theories are that this is gallifrey
or it’s a post-war trenzalore.
The other planets could be moons and Gallifrey
does have or did have two moons.
Supposedly they were destroyed during the
time war.
But because of the 50th those could be back
with gallifrey.
After staring at this and thinking more about
trenzalore I had the thought that it might
be more evidence capaldi is the actual fulfillment
of the silence’s prophecy about the first
question.
Capaldi has made a very big deal about “Questions”
so far.
Just more things to add to the theory pile.
But just as a reminder going forward, as we
get more information about Missy and the promised
land.
Think about the planets in the title sequence
and how they all might be connected.
Question 8 - Michelle Sloney asks this episode
reminded me of the classic who episode where
the doctor met all the fairy tale characters.
Which episode was that?
You’re thinking of the Mind Robber from
the second doctor’s run.
I don’t know if Mark Gatiss wrote it this
way intentionally but the story of that episode
had some similar themes.
The fairy tale characters call the Doctor
a traitor because they view him as a fairy
tale character who rebelled.
Robin Hood’s speech at the end of this week’s
episode was all about the thought that it
doesn’t matter whether or not the story
is real, just that the story serves as a call
to action for people reading it.
It’s a nice meta-commentary on the power
of fiction.
Part of me wants to think that Missy is someone
inspired by The Doctor’s story and is doing
what she believes to be a great work in his
name.
Like saving people for him.
Like she’s his crazy fan.
Question 9 - Paul Cagliarini asks what do
you think of the Madame de Pompadour Missy
theory.
The robots were a more advanced version of
the clockwork droids, so it’s possible Missy
has Madame de Pompadour’s brain?
That’s definitely an interesting way to
think about her.
Madame de Pompadour could still be holding
on to her idea of the doctor as her boyfriend
if her brain has survived in a very advanced
robot body.
And as cool as the thought is, I’m really
hoping Missy turns out to be a completely
new character.
I have a feeling that if she is an old classic
who character, no matter what the explanation
is, most people will wind up dissapointed.
Fan theories like the ones we talk about here
are always going to be way more complicated
and interesting that the reality.
I think Missy being someone new or new as
in, she’s someone from the doctor’s past,
but not someone the show has done before.
I think that just gives Moffat and future
showrunners more material to work with.
I just feel like people would get tired of
it faster if they just kept recycling old
things over and over.
Question 10 - Trent McIntire asks do you think
when Moffat leaves we’ll see the master
again?
I took this more as a do you think future
showrunners will bring other old stuff back.
There’s definitely things Moffat has said
he’s not touching because Russell Davies
did them.
Or things he didn’t want to do because he
thought he had nothing worthwhile to add.
I think of all the things he hasn’t done,
future showrunners would probably search for
the most open ended stories from classic who
to build on.
Like ones that focused more on characters
that already haven’t been done again in
new Who.
Since Davies did the Master, I’m betting
unless Missy is a female master, we won’t
see him again until the next anniversary special.
The 10th anniversary of New Who is March 26th
2015.
Since the christmas special is the next big
special, I don’t know that the BBC is producing
any special content.
But hopefully by the series 8 finale.
They’ll let us know whether or not a 10th
anniversary episode is coming.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions.
These are always a ton of fun.
I’m really liking series 8 so far.
There’s so many new things to theorycraft.
My next bonus video will be for my favorite
scary doctor who stories just because Listen
looks like it’s going to be pretty scary.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
I’ll try to post it before episode 4 airs.
Congratulations to this week’s giveaway
winner Carmen Chan.
You win an amazon giftcard.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Next round of the giveaway starts when I post
my episode 4 video.
In the meantime click here for my episode
3 review and click here for my top 10 historical
doctor who characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight
for game of thrones.
High Fives!